it was a dream wedding for Sofia Vergara
and Joe Manganiello
and only et is with the man behind the
bride's party dress Saturday night
Sofia wanted something that was sexy she
wanted something that was playful
designer mark Zunino says the curve
hugging creation got just the reaction
from joe that sofia was looking for
Sofia just wanted to make sure that she
felt that he would just love it when he
saw it on her somebody messaged me from
the wedding when she'd put it on and
said that his eyes just fell out of his
head he thought she looked so sexy
that's exactly what we wanted who can
blame him mark shared exclusive pics of
Sofia's fitting and we agree she stunned
we had four women working three weeks on
it so it was quite a process to make
this all happen the wedding weekend
itself was also quite a process but mark
says Sofia was far from a bridezilla
she's not one of those Brides that
worried about everything she just knew
she wanted to have fun and I think
everything just fell into place because
of it